voilà forcément beaucoup d'inquiétude
bruno daroux le conseil de sécurité de
l'onu est sur le point de se réunir une
fois de plus mais cette fois sur le
thème de cet incident nucléaire qu'est
ce qu'on peut en attendre de cette
réunion à écouter comme on est au niveau
du conseil de sécurité avec donc les
cinq membres permanents dont la russie
membre permanent qui disposent chacun
d'un droit de veto forcément on peut pas
en attendre grand chose puisqu'il a à
peu près sûr à 100% que la russie va
mettre son droit de veto l'objectif des
britanniques et aussi des américains en
l'occurrence et de condamner ce qu'a
fait la russie de deux dons de viser
comme ça une centrale nucléaire même si
les russes quand même savez sans doute
qu'il faisait puisque en fait ils n'ont
pas visé les réacteurs il y avait sans
doute de la part des russes la volonté
un de terroriser d'effrayer un peu les
populations acridiennes et puis bien au
delà les populations européennes d'une
part puis d'autre part peut-être aussi
on ne dit pas beaucoup mais de s'emparer
d'une arme économique importante
rappelle que cette centrale nucléaire
qui est la plus grande en europe mais
dessert évidemment l'ukraine et fournit
20% de l'électricité en ukraine donc
mettre la main sur un apport et gc aussi
contrôler quelque part l'outil de
l'électricité dont on sait
malheureusement qui peut être utilisée
pour contraindre des habitants notamment
à acquitter des villes donc le le vote
au conseil de sécurité très certainement
se traduira par un échec en terme
d'adoption de la résolution
ça va confirmer aussi sans doute quand
même on verra comment votre les dix
membres non permanents mais ça va
confirmer sans doute l' isolement de la
russie fera quand même surveiller le
vote de ses dix membres non permanents
parce que par exemple un c'était à
s'étaient abstenus lors des votes le
week-end dernier au conseil de sécurité
et puis de l'isolément a été fortement
marquée évidemment lors du vote de la
session extraordinaire de l'assemblée
générale de l'onu mais là c'est
l'ensemble des 193 pays qui sont réunies
il n'y a pas de droit de veto donc là la
sentence a été assez amer pour la russie
jusqu'à 141 pays qui ont condamné
l'invasion de l'ukraine par moscou 14 se
sont abstenus et seulement
5 cinq seulement ont voté avec la russie
merci bruno daroux chroniqueur
international merci d'avoir été en
direct avec nous sur sur ce plateau